me
医師の
ます
はじめまして
この後自己紹介しようと思うんですが
皆さん自己紹介得意な人いますか
否かあまりないです
さっきの旅人小峠さんとか特にそうですよねー
立ってるプロの1発汗でハイカーですよ
よくわかんないけどいいなん
自己紹介で決まっていうのは名前と肩書きと
よろしくお願いしますこの3つだけ
この3つだけで初めましての人にうまく自分が伝えられる人いいますか
私はどうしても不安になって
素の自分が出てこなくて
ずーっと猫被ってしまいます
自分の自己紹介します
信州大学工学部建築学科待つ間パーキーアプロジェクトの代表をしています
東あやかですよろしくお願いします
ん
私の肩書きは信州大学工学部建築落下
トーマツまた空き家プロジェクト代表
この2つでした
この肩書きは私を変えました
建築っていう肩書から始まった松野ターキーあプロジェクトは私を変えたんです
集まったキュアプロジェクトわー
学生等行きの人をつなぐ巣作り
大好きのメンバー5人で運営しています
服ににクラピーつって幸喜県にプロ5
一緒に始めたあけお1アーリーて探した明けを使ってメンバー
一緒に
企画を考えたりご飯を食べたり
この前は皆で一緒に鍋食べました鍋つついて
またをこたつもらったのでみんなでぬくぬくしたりお昼寝したり
そんな大事な私の居場所です
きっかけは1年前でした
秋谷もう書づくりも
ほとんど知らなかったけどなんとなく気になってて
その時に
一緒にやらないって空き家探して墓所ずくしないって
誘ってもらいました
それから
一緒に行ってくれる友達がいるならいいかなと思って始めました
それからいろんな不つながりが不不不不不不不得手
こうやって家もペットの舞台に立たせてもらってますが
最初はこれ本当にやろうかなって大丈夫かなぁって思って始まったプロジェクトでした
無事に空き家を借りる形が出来て
嬉しい方に少し爪が曲がって
松またキュアプロジェクトっていう気質か私にとって良い働きをしてくれています
初めましての人に空き家プロジェクトやってるんですって言うと知ってるー空き家
プロジェクトって言ってもらったりとか
それだけじゃないです
本当にいろんな人と出会うことがあって
人との出会いが嬉しくて
最近その話を試合の1にしたんですね最近こんなかっこいい人と出会えてこんなすごい
人いたんですってそしたら言われました
すって
空き家プロジェクト代表だからだよねって
そうなんです県プロジェクト代表なんだからだけど
んでも
それは私自身じゃないじゃんって肩書きじゃんって
私自身空っぽカーって
でも考え直しました
空っぽでも肩書きがあったからそういう人と出会えたんだってな鏡がなくても後で補え
ばいいかって
松また空き家プロジェクトの始まりはすごく些細なことでした
誘ってもらって
でもモヤモヤしてた時に一歩踏み出して肩書きをつくって
つながりができて
私が帰ることになったきっかけでした
敵が私をあた押ししてくれました
一歩踏み出せない
もやもやしている何かやりたいんだけどなって思っているそんな人に届けたい
型月の使い方取扱説明書になります
目次肩書きの組み立て方から頭の使い方
主よ以上のうちの3編になります肩書きの組み立て方
使うにはまず持ってないとダメです肩書き
作りましょう
皆さん箱を思い浮かべてみてください
箱ですこれはあなた自身です
この箱に名前をつけるんです自分の気になっているキーワードと
プロジェクトって言葉を組み合わせて名前を付けます
まるまるプロジェクト
先ほどの空き家プロジェクトを思い出してみてください
知らなくても
空き家で何か夜のかなって気になりますよね
名前を付けるんです
でも
宗教的な怪しい名前にはならないように注意です
梅を漬けたら2つ目頭を見つけましょう
誰かを一緒に守ってくれる仲間
今あなたがやろうとしていることは一人霊的そうですか
つの体型やプロジェクトもあり方が仲間が入ったから楽しいって思えたし続けたいって
思うことができました
仲間を見つけます
今何かやりたいって思っているあなたに必要なのは
名前をつけることと仲間を見つけることこの2つだけです
2つだけ
でも
服を作る時に一つだけコツがあります
地中なことからやること
別に陥らことをやろうとしなくてもいい別に社会がたぶん逆に叩くてもいいと思うん
です
形だけの箱はあなたがミラすために
手助けしてくれるものです
ちっちゃくてもいいから復興作ることコツはこれだけです
じゃあ次泊を作ったとします
箱を作って
名前も付けて a 仲間も見つけました
もう一方
発信します
みなさんこれ気になりましたよね最初持ってきたかな箱
何もなかった箱に打つもタイプやプロジェクトって
できました
入ってみんなに見せておいてきっと興味を持ってくれた人がいると思うんです
この箱は
空っぽです
タラップの肩書の箱
これは何もないって思っている自分自身と同じです
でも何もなくても手間をつけて皆に見せてキャメ持ってもらったらそれがスタートです
スタートして発信をすることからこの空っぽの箱は溜まっていきます
どんどん重くなって
どんどん頑張りがたまって
そんな姿を見てー
手伝ってくれる人が現れます
妻た空き家プロジェクトもう
手伝ってくれる人がいました
お金がない来てー
知識もなくて条文もなくて一種の私たちを見て手伝ってくれる人興味を持ってくれる人
たくさんいました
最初ということやりたいって言って8-1山にこういうこうこういうことしたくて
明らかしてほしいんですって言ったら
うんそういうことならいいよってかしてくれたりとか
ちょっと私たちがないものをくれたりとか
空き家に来てくれる人がいたりとか
頑張りの次に箱にたまるのは感謝の気持ちです
空っぽだと思ってた箱はいつのまにか
アグレ出るほどに満杯になっていくんです
少し自分が変わったって思うほどに
ここで使用上の注意があります
たくさん持ち歩かないこと
少し自分が変わったって思えるほどに方が機能とは
いっぱいになりました
箱は役目を終え始めています
溜まったのは頑張った気持ちと感謝
これは肩書きを手放しても
働きじゃ表せない自分自身がいるはずです
満杯になった子はちょっとを言って新しい
空っぽの箱を持ち上げて新しいスタートです
新しい挑戦
私も今アフリカに興味があって
動き出しています
まったく空き家プロジェクトとは関係がないけど人と出会うで嬉しさは変わらず私です
新しい挑戦
二つ目は片岡機に怯えないかと
肩書はあなたが一歩踏み出せない勇気が出ないっていうときに手助けをしてくれるもの
です
噛む人がどんなに大きな箱を持ってたり
キラキラした墓を持ってても
あなたには関係はないことで
気にしても意味がありません見えないこと
肩書きの集取扱説明書は以上になります
ないないない
いいものないいいところないなって思ってた自分も
肩書きを持ったことで
一歩踏み出せました
肩書きを持ったことでやりたいって思えたしやらなきゃって思いました
ん
キットっ
やりたいことがあると思っている人は気づいているはずです
ことは一歩踏み出せないのは
言い訳をしてるだけってことに
肩書はそんな私を支えてくれました
動き出そうとしてあなたを肩書は帰ってくれるはずです
それぞれをまだヒントが足りないって人は
ペットが他の面白い取扱説明書を出しているのでオススメです
私が今日皆さんに渡すのは鳥が来肩書きの取扱説明書です
ありがとうございました